Russland beschießt die Ukraine seit 230
Tagen mit Raketen und der jüngste Bombe
in Hagel war gezielter Terror gegen die
Zivilbevölkerung ein Kriegsverbrechen
sagen Militärexperten ja die Bomben sie
schlugen mitten im Zentrum Kiews ein
dort gibt es keine militärischen Ziele
getroffen wurden Wohnhäuser und Sie
sehen es hier ein Spielplatz und genau
dort steht jetzt unser Bild Reporter
Bild Vize Paul ronsheimer Paul es ist
die erste Nacht nach den neuen
Terrorangriffen Russlands auf die
Ukraine mit wie viel Angst mit wie viel
Furcht startet Kiew heute in diesem Tag
keine Angst keine Furcht die ich erleben
kann zumindest auf den Straßen und auch
hier denn nur weniger als 24 Stunden
nachdem hier etwas eingeschlagen ist ich
zeige euch noch einmal wie heftig dieser
Krater hier ist aber nur wenige Stunden
nachdem und obwohl es gerade eben wieder
Bombenalarm gab wird hier aufgeräumt so
wie in der ganzen Stadt man will die
Spuren der Verwüstung so schnell wie
möglich vergessen machen denn die
Ukraine die ukrainische Regierung sagt
wir lassen uns nicht terrorisieren wir
lassen uns keine Angst machen wir werden
weitermachen mit der Militär gegen
Offensive im Osten im Süden und das ist
die Aussage der ukrainischen offiziellen
wir holen uns unser Land zurück Paul es
war ja eine massive Angriffswelle die
die Ukraine jetzt noch mal erlebt hat
nicht nur in Kiew sind Bomben gefallen
auch in sehr vielen anderen Städten des
Landes teure Präzisionsraketen die da
eingesetzt wurden von Vladimir p das
Truppen wie lange kann er diese
Strategie denn überhaupt durchhalten und
was ist das für eine Strategie die er da
verfolgt
es kann keiner genau sagen wie viele er
von diesen Waffen tatsächlich hat wie
viele von diesen
hochmodernen Raketen und auch weniger
modernen Raketen es gibt einige Experten
die sagen dass er das nicht lange
durchhalten wird können und das
sozusagen der Vorrat schon fast leer sei
aber tatsächlich seriös kann das niemand
sagen das ist ein natürlich ein
militärgeheimnis dort in Russland aber
die Strategie von Wladimir Putin ist
ganz klar man will Terror man will Angst
verbreiten weil man in der Front also im
Osten und im Süden nicht weiterkommt
weil man dort Boden verliert und er
sozusagen mit dieser Antwort hier rund
um Kiew rund um saporisha heute morgen
auch wieder wo Raketen eingeschlagen
sind zeigen will dass er zumindest die
Zivilbevölkerung terrorisieren kann das
wiederum gibt ihm Applaus von der
russischen Propaganda von denjenigen die
er dort braucht aber und das ist ganz
wichtig zu betonen militärisch ändert
das erst einmal gar ist das ändert
nichts an der Front ganz im Gegenteil da
gewinnt die Ukraine teilweise eben
weiter zwar nur ein paar Dörfer aber das
geht stetig seit Wochen seit Monaten
dieser Angriffe das wild um sich
schlagen das hat dann am Ende nur ein
propagandaziel für die russische Führung
dafür dass man zeigen kann wir sind
stark wir kämpfen weiter Paul danke
schön für deine ganz aktuelle
Einschätzung aus Kiew
so und diese bombenwelle also Putins
Rache für die Explosion auf die
krimbrücke mehr als 100 Raketen feuert
Russland auf die Ukraine ab den Putin
der will Rache ja die Moral der Ukrainer
zerstören mit Angst mit Schrecken früh
morgens zur
es ist ein ungleicher Kampf mit
Marschflugkörpern und Präzisionswaffen
gegen zivile Ziele
der Kontrast er könnte nicht größer sein
aus der Entfernung befiehlt der
Kremlherrscher und Ukrainisch Präsident
wurde du mir selenski steht in
Militärkleidung an einer Kreuzung die am
Montag von einer russischen Rakete
verwüstet wurde
Ukraine lässt sich nicht einschüchtern
sie wird nur noch mehr vereint die
Ukraine ist nicht aufzuhalten nur noch
mehr davon überzeugt dass Terroristen
neutralisiert werden müssen
silenski eine Identifikationsfigur so
wie der Bürgermeister von Kiew Vitali
Klitschko auch er nicht in sicherer
Entfernung er besucht eine nach ihm
benannte Fußgängerbrücke die von
Raketenangriffen getroffen wurde die
klitschko-brücke ist ein Wahrzeichen im
Zentrum von Kiew
Überwachungskameras filmten die
Explosion
[Musik]
ich sehe hier Trümmer raketensplitter
überall Glasscherben aber ich bin
überzeugt dass wir das alles wieder
aufbauen werden
dann filmt er noch an einer anderen
Stelle filmt mit seiner Handykamera im
Zentrum von Kiew hinter ihm ein riesiger
Krater
es war ein Terrorakt von russischen
Barbaren auf die Hauptstadt und die
regionalen Zentren der Ukraine in Kiew
wurden am Morgen und im Laufe des Tages
mehrere Stellen getroffen insbesondere
die Innenstadt der Irre Aggressor traf
die kritische Infrastruktur der
Hauptstadt alle städtischen Dienste
Arbeiten im Notfallmodus reagieren
umgehend und bewältigen die Folgen des
Angriffs
die tödlichen Raketenangriffe gegen
mehrere Städte
sie zerstören zivile Ziele treffen die
Strom- und Wasserversorgung Gebäude
Menschen insgesamt elf Tote und etwa 70
verletzte die Angriffe sie fanden in den
Morgenstunden statt mitten im
Berufsverkehr und aus sicherer
Entfernung wenn das nicht Terror ist was
dann
Russland überzieht die Ukraine also mit
Luftangriffen flächendeckend denn der
Druck auf Kreml Diktator Putin der
wächst ja schuld sind die diversen
kriegsklatschen also die Gebietsverluste
der letzten Wochen die Hardliner um ihn
herum die wollen jetzt mehr eine
deutlich härtere Gangart nun scheint es
also so als komme der Kreml-Chef diesen
Forderungen auch nach
es ist die Allianz des Grauens Putins
neue Bluthunde im Kampf gegen die
Ukraine im Zentrum diese drei Männer
Alexander Lukaschenko der belarussische
Diktator steht schon lange an Putins
Seite und stellt jetzt seine
Militärstützpunkte für die russischen
Angriffe bereitwillig zur Verfügung
mehr noch er will sogar mit Putin eine
Armee Gründen der Grund Lukaschenko habe
über inoffizielle Kanäle erfahren dass
die Ukraine Angriffe auf Weißrussland
planen Lukaschenko selbst scheut nicht
die Ukraine selbst anzugreifen laut
Experten kamen mehrere Raketen bei den
Angriffen auf Kiew aus Weißrussland
Sergeis surowikin die neuesten Angriffe
auf die Ukraine sie tragen seine
Handschrift Sergej surowikin Putin
schlechter verübte schon in Syrien die
grausamsten Kriegsverbrechen bombte dort
zwischen 2017 und 2019 die Rebellen
nieder brachte deren Familien hinter der
Front um Krankenhäuser Schulen und
Getreidesilos waren seine beliebtesten
Ziele besonders grausam er soll neue
russische Waffensysteme an syrischen
Zivilisten getestet haben
Ramsan kadurov Putins Bluthund brutal
radikal loyal der tschetschenische
Präsident steht bereits seit
Kriegsbeginn an Putins Seite und
unterstützt den kremeldiktator mit fast
80.000 Männern die eben skrupellos und
brutal sind wie er seine Blutrünstigkeit
kennt kaum Grenzen er fordert schon
Russland ein noch härteres Vorgehen will
unter anderem Tier stürmen und den
Einsatz von Atomwaffen Putins Terror
fällt Herren sie ziehen für ihn in den
Krieg
[Musik]